hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
briefs now there was another update to
the game that added some new features
and fixed a lot of bugs but
unfortunately wipe my save again which
means that I got to start from the
beginning but you guys don't need to
worry about that all you guys are gonna
see is a montage of jump-scare so be
prepared for loud noises random things
happening because I'm gonna try my best
to get back to where I was before but it
may take a while and it may stop if it's
just too much for my nimble brain bring
it on I ain't scared of nobody except
for Billy that guy says keep your eyes
on
well that's who is he still down there
Oh Oh see down there he's down there
isn't he
son of a biscuit a Kapoor Polly he's in
there but I don't have my gas mask it
would be horribly stupid of me to go in
there
wait is he in there did he go away some
about me done trust that [ __ ] okay but I
think he's in there anyway
well who's hiding in a corner let dick
hello elevator what do you have for me
blood my favorite no belly
hey warning oh you got a will he will he
will open oven oven oven come across
close oh god damn it
it's one big cycle this is the same
isn't it it's the same as the other one
is this goddamn same what what do I do
now I gotta go back oh thank you Hey
hey Bailey you're looking handsome as
ever I'm a boy I'm like hi goddamn
double - piece of [ __ ] ass poop which
way am I facing now which way am I going
this way now get through the goddamn
door panner
cleaner oh I know I didn't go this way
yet that's musta gotten flipped II
flipped okay you come here you turn SCP
in teddy
nope good the light is gone that's a
good sign I think sunshine happiness
we're about to shoot out my butthole uh
[ __ ] off
I'm not Carson uh who Clarkson is he's
probably a dead guy on the floor back
there take the shorts way out it did die
quickly
oh it wasn't that thing that could kill
us
boy are you dead oh I'm dead - okay yes
finally I got a key card
make a left I will eventually get to
where [ __ ] must been that way I don't
remember going this way
what is that thunder stairs welcome to
the fun house this is where the fun
happens I'm so ready to have fun take
this nice and slow nice and gentle don't
you touch it
sorry I have the Black Lung do not mind
me mine me
no oh you didn't see me dancing don't
see me you're blind
no you bet oh did it never lock your
Dylan's I think we doubled our utility
[ __ ] oh okay you're fun you're fun
well this is a fun time bubbly leave now
okay okay okay this is normal yeah we're
having a fun time here okay all right
then alrighty then
that's rise again huh with less gomez me
breath stupid toggle to crouch oh hi
yeah keep on moving no one who the hell
was that stop bothering my buddy over
here
go ahead Jeremy its it's fine
oh they won't bother you boo is that you
playing the sousaphone over there is one
of your playing the bassoon or is that
just another bass yeah you go Oh hurry
up that's right okay okay
who's that no one I'm going screw you
guys are you screaming stupid
I thought I was dead oh my god yeah I
made it over save the goddamn game thank
you oh yay
so I'll put this in the thing don't do
that
what did you just did okay so anyway
that's cool mine's I might be able to go
around make my way downtown
moving past out of homebound
okay okay
who's our triple drop of blood
did I hear a drippy drop okay fun
another one or did I just get turned
around again cuz douche buzz goosh goosh
goosh no it's a new hot why are you
there they're thousands you not what
happen what in the world that's normal
good that's not good
oh why now Billy Billy I don't need this
I'm right here
maybe you can't get through these doors
maybe also I'm a big idiot oh I'm going
I'm going I'm bone alone I'm balling
around
I'll give me by saying give it give it
give it give you
Oh poopy nuggets why am I here
I haven't been here in a while so I
guess I'll explore on dead I'm dead
oh I thought you'd get thrala poor me
Trelleborg now I'm gonna Duke you like
nobody's been Jude before joking joking
initiated Jake grabbing joking away
uh-huh
got it how do you do sh take you through
the door
oh wait wait oh that's exactly what that
guy can do oh there's a goddamn heavy
can do is this it this better be it
there we go good for me thanks thanks
for the acknowledgement scream okay
doing good that's me breathing that's me
breathing that's nothing else that's me
breathing too much out is that it Billy
that was a billy close it close it
please close it close it close that damn
tight no no Billy hi you're just over
there why are you over here now you want
to hold hands
you're so pretty goodbye forever
where Z where Z where Z which way to go
was that high belly close am close it up
yard ah
hi okay I'm gonna ignore you and close
this thank you how nice a far gone
forever and I okay now is new what down
Oh
- these I call me in the morning when
you're dead don't do [ __ ] okay okay so
there was a radical Larry who's
radically stupid up here so you're a
trap ancient Oh goddamn it that means
I'm sandwiched in between you and Billy
it's a Billy Larry sandwich and I don't
want to be a part of it I'm out of bran
juice is right behind me I am eternally
screwed aren't I
okay I am excuse me she's gonna slap god
damn it
oh god I've boned her owned myself well
anyway I think that's as good a place as
any to stop I have made some progress
I'll be able to cheat my way out of that
little deathtrap there but either way
thank you all so much for watching hope
you enjoyed this little SCP scare
montage of what it was you can check out
the other SCP videos that I have I have
a ton of them they're like 40 or more of
them in the link in the annotation or in
the description or at the end Slade over
there so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next
okay